Let me begin by saying I know
there are millions of Americans,
millions of Americans
in this country
who feel disappointed and discouraged
or even a little bit angry
about the court's
decision today on student debt.
And I must admit, I do, too.
Before I tell you,
the steps we're going to take
and want to talk about will be able
I want to tell you what we were able
to achieve
so far
on student loan over the past few years.
First,
we made the largest increase
in Pell Grants in over a decade,
helping students and families
who nearly
all make less than $60,000 a year.
Then we fixed the so so-called
with the help of a department
public service loan forgiveness program.
So the borrowers
who got into public service,
such as schoolteachers,
police officers,
social workers, service members,
you know,
they actually got the debt relief
they into every title under the law
before I came to office.
Only 7000 people have benefited
from that program today.
Over 600,000 borrowers are receiving
from that program and are still able
so many people more
so many more people can be helped.
And I encourage you to apply
if you haven't already.
You're still eligible.
Go to student aid that govt matters.
Third
administration approved a program
from the Obama-Biden administration,
an income driven repayment plan
That's what I was referring to at
back then. We set a limit.
Student borrowers
would pay no more
than 10% of their disposable income
to pay back their debt at any one time.
My administration
is going to reduce that to 5%
is now the most generous repayment
program ever.
No one with an undergraduate loan today
or in the future,
whether from a community college
or a Four-Year
College, will have
to pay
more than 5% of the disposable income
to repay their loan.
And that's income
after you pay for the necessities like
housing, food and the like.
Typical
bar is going to save about $1,000 a year.
And if you keep up payments for 20 years
without Michigan,
your total debt is forgiven
after 20 years.
That's what the program was before.
But we've just reduced to 5%.
In addition to that, last year
I announced my student debt relief plan,
a plan
that was on the verge of providing
more than 40 million Americans
with real debt relief up to $10,000
for many borrowers,
and up to 20,000
for those who had gotten a Pell Grant.
Nearly 90% of the relief
began to borrowers,
90% of it
making less than $75,000 a year.
And no one no one making over 125,000
would qualify
This program was all set to begin.
The website had been set up.
Applications had been simplified
so that it took less
than 5 minutes to complete.
Notice had been sent out to people
about the relief they were eligible for.
16 million people.
16 million people
had already been approved.
The money was literally
about to go out the door.
And then Republican elected officials
and special interests stepped in.
They said, No, no,
literally snatching
from the hands of millions
Americans, thousands of dollars
in debt relief
that was about to change their lives.
You know, these Republican officials
just couldn't bear
the thought of providing relief
for working
class, middle class Americans.
Republican state officials
sued my administration,
attempting to block relief,
including millions
of their own constituents
You probably seen
Congress voted to overturn the plan.
I think everyone
I don't think
I named Republican votes for this plan
the same time.
Think about this.
We've all supported the paycheck
protection program.
Remember PGP,
you know,
which was designed
to help business owners who lost money
because the pandemic
was worth the program.
But let's be clear,
some of the same elected Republicans,
members of Congress
who strongly oppose
can release the students,
got hundreds
of thousands of dollars of cells
and really members of Congress
because of the
businesses they were able
to keep up with.
Seven members of Congress
got over $1,000,000
all those loans are forgiven.
Now, how much of that program cost?
$760 billion?
My program's too expensive.
$360 billion more than I proposed
the most in debt relief program.
I was trying to provide students with ten
to 25,
ten to $20,000 relief by comparison.
The average amount forgiven in the
pandemic loan program.
Average amount for them was $70,000.
Our kid making
60,000 bucks
trying to pay back his bills
asking for $10,000 a relief.
Come on.
The hypocrisy is stunning.
He can't help a family making 75
grand a year.
But you can help a millionaire
and you have your debt forgiven.
My plan
will not only have life in life change.
1 million Americans
would have been good for the American
economy,
free millions of Americans
with a crushing burden of student debt.
More homes bought,
more businesses would have been started.
More couples would have had to compromise
to start a family.
Millions of people would have felt
they could get on with their life.
These Republicans blocked all that.
Now, in addition
to the hypocrisy
of some of these Republican colleagues
are shamelessly pushing
to advance the bill
in the coming weeks
to gives
hundreds of billions of dollars
in tax breaks
it hand out to the wealthiest Americans.
They still haven't given up
on making permanent
a $2 trillion tax cut that they
never paid for,
never paid
for $2 trillion.
So let me be clear.
Republicans in Congress, it's
not about reducing the deficit.
It's not about fairness.
And forgive me,
Lance, It's only about forgiving loans
they have to pay.
Today, the Supreme Court sided with them.
I believe the court's decision
to strike down my student debt
relief program was a mistake, was wrong.
I'm not going to stop
fighting to deliver borrowers
what they need,
particularly those at the bottom
end of the economic scale.
So we need to find a new way
to remove it as fast as we can.
First, I'm announcing today
a new path consistent with today's
ruling to provide student debt
relief
to as many borrowers as possible
as quickly as possible.
We will ground this new approach
in a different law than my original plan.
A so-called Higher Education Act
that will allow.
Secretary Cardona was with me today
to compromise,
waive or release
loans under certain circumstances.
This new path and legally sound
is going to take longer.
And in my view, is the best
path to be managed,
providing for many borrowers possible
with debt relief.
I'm directing my team to move
as quickly as possible.
Just moments ago,
Secretary Cardona
took the first step
to initially initiate that new approach.
We're not going to waste
any time on this.
We're getting moving on every second.
Take longer.
We get it right away.
Second,
we know what many borrowers
will need to make their hard choices,
which they're
which their budgets are being strained
now when they start
to repay their monthly loan payments
this fall.
You know, we know that figuring out
how to pay these out
expenses can take time for borrowers
and they might miss payments
at the front end
as they get back into repayment.
Normally,
this could lead borrowers
to fall into delinquency in default,
but without their financial,
it would hurt their financial security.
And that's not good for them
or the economy.
That's why
we're creating a temporary 12 month.
What we're calling on ramp
repayment program
now so that the same as the
student loan pause,
it's been in effect for
the past three years.
Monthly payments will be due,
bills will not go out
and interest will be accrued
And during this period,
if you can pay your monthly bills,
you should.
But if you cannot, if you miss payments
this on ramp
temporarily remove the threat of default
or having your credit harmed,
which can hurt borrowers
for years to come.
Because the Department of Education
won't refer borrowers.
And the reason
why with that word,
they won't refer borrowers
who missed payments
to credit agencies for 12 months
to give them a chance
to get back up and running.
Let me close with this.
A Republican officials say
student loan
relief is a giveaway to the privilege.
You hear that now the privileged
Love their concern for the privilege.
But I know student
loan borrowers are in this country.
So are you comfortable
putting off having a child
until they can find their way
to deal with their debt?
Actually, they are very young for
not buying their first home,
but they get out from under
student loans.
Hope on the horizon thanks to relief
I plan last year.
Today's caucuses start away from.
I get it. I get it.
I hear this.
It's and I'm concerned about.
But today's decision is close.
One that now we're going to pursue
another.
I'm never going to stop fighting for you.
We use every tool at our disposal
to get you the student debt
relief you need and reach your dreams.
It's good for the economy.
It's good for the country.
It's going to be good for you.
Thank you very, very much for listening.
We're going to get this done.
God willing.
Thank you, Mr. President.
Why did you give millions of borrowers
false hope?
You've dated,
doubted your own authority
here in the past?
I didn't give any false hope.
The question was whether or not
I would do even more than was requested.
What I did,
I felt, was appropriate
and was able to be done
and would get done.
I didn't give borrowers false hope,
but the Republicans snatched away
the hope that they were given.
And it's real, real hope.
Thank you, Mr. President.
But you can say that you already did.
You overstepped the authority.
I think the court misinterpret
the Constitution.
Mr. President, what do you mean?
The failure in Afghanistan?
Mistakes.
There was
there was
a report on Afghanistan in withdrawal
saying there was failure or mistakes.
Do you admit
there was mistakes during the withdrawal
and before
all the evidence is coming back here?
Remember what I said about Afghanistan?
I said Al Qaida would not be there.
We said it wouldn't be.
I said we get help from the Taliban.
What's happening now?
What's going on?
Read your press.
I was right
Thanks.
So far.
So the report is from the State
Department, actually,
about the withdrawal.